five songs have been presented in
performance it's time to review them and
see which becomes eligible for inclusion
and all those albums of Oscar winners
sure to be recorded in the future to
make the presentation we looked outside
Daisy clover and found beautiful Natalie
Wood
what's that strange noise rapping oh
that's the sound of ten songwriters
gnawing on 90 fingernails and five
agents gnawing on the other 10% the
nominees for best song first used in an
eligible motion picture are Jerry
Livingston and Mack David for the ballot
of Cat Ballou Michelle lagron and
Jacques Demy
for I will wait for you Johnny Mandel
and Paul Francis Webster for the shadow
of your smile Henry Mancini and Johnny
Mercer for the sweetheart tree and Burt
Bacharach and Hal David for what's new
pussycat now I have young help the
winners are Johnny Mandel and Paul
Francis Webster
Paul you're a little better at this are
just one second you're a while I'm
deeply honored and very proud thank you
very much
wow this is probably the proudest moment
I can remember I'd like to thank
everyone like to thank particular Marty
Rantzen Hall gave me the job in the
first place